un nouveau parquet pour cette deuxième
saison en pro b tous les voyants sont au
vert pour le club de batteries blésois
les joueurs de l'ada blois sont ravis de
pouvoir en 117 salle juste pour génial
au quotidien parce que c'est toujours
sympa de travailler dans un bel endroit
là des niveau du confort cc c'est
beaucoup mieux que ce qu'on a connu un
pas par le passé il ya pas de pression à
avoir gagné des matches si ce gain des
matches ce n'est pas une salle qui nous
met la pression après oui il ya une
attente de résultat mais ça ça a
toujours été le cas donc non ça n'est
pas de prescience et c'est positif
il reste beaucoup de choses à mettre en
place avant le 3 septembre date du
premier match et des tiers la salle de
muscu le 22 kg aux thérapies le flocage
du parquet le club petit à petit se
professionnaliser davantage en termes
d'obligations administratives auprès de
la ligue nationale de basket on a
beaucoup de choses encore à cadrer on
intègre aussi des nombreux salariés
qu'il faut accompagner dans leur dans
leur arrivée dans le club que ce soit
sur le marketing sur l'administratif qui
viennent soutenir et épauler déjà ce
qu'ils ont fait un gros travail depuis
plusieurs années est rentré avec un
objectif sportif pérenniser la da boa
dans le club très fermé des équipes pros
pour y imposer son jeu
ça nous rend très important parce que ça
permet déjà de le mettre en place les
bases de l'équipe
notre façon de jouer et c'est vrai que
les premiers jours d'entraînement au
delà du volume physique 44 important on
met en place ce projet dieu rendez-vous
le premier week-end de septembre pour
les premières passes et des premiers
paniers blésois contre poitiers